the leader of a doomsday cult linked to
hundreds of deaths in eastern Kenya is
due to appear in court Paul Mckenzie was
denied bail last month and is facing
charges including terrorism and
kidnapping the court is deciding whether
to extend his pre-trial detention the
scale of the crimes McKenzie is accused
of is still emerging in April police
acting on a tip-off started searching a
forest near the coastal town of malindi
and began to uncover a number of mass
Graves Mackenzie later turned himself
into authorities as leader of the Good
News International Church he is accused
of ordering followers to starve
themselves to death so they could go to
heaven before the end of the world
two months on bodies are still being
discovered more than 250 have been
exhumed so far eight of them just on
Tuesday and hundreds of people are still
missing Malcolm Webb is in Nairobi
Malcolm the pastor is due in court where
are we in these legal proceedings
the court is in the process of deciding
whether or not it will grant the
prosecutions requests to detain
Mackenzie for a further 60 days while
they continue with the investigation the
prosecution last week said they need
this extra time to continue exhuming
bodies to identify the bodies that
they've exhumed and also to gather
statements from the witnesses from the
survivors who were rescued from the
Colts settlement in the shakahola forest
alive many of them still appear to be
under the influence of McKenzie and the
prosecution says it's taking time to be
able to gather statements or Witnesses
who would testify against him now the
defense has said that McKenzie should be
either charged with a crime or released
that seems unlikely at this stage the
whole matter has become so embarrassing
for the authorities and for the state a
release does indeed seem unlikely and
just yesterday on Tuesday at the burial
site the internal affairs minister went
there to launch the resumption of
exclamations of bodies he himself said
that McCann he will remain in jail until
they've been able to do the prosecution
of being able to put together a case now
we've just heard in the last few moments
from the court that it's actually been
adjourned until Friday because the
prosecutor the lead prosecutor is
himself unwell
Malcolm outside the courtroom how's this
playing out I just wonder how it's
percolating through Kenyan Society
well many people in malindi say that if
Mackenzie was released then he'd very
likely be harmed and or even killed by
an Angry Crowd it wouldn't even be safe
for him to go on the street now because
people are so angry Having learned about
what he's uh widely suspected to have
done ordering uh or killing hundreds of
his uh followers there's also a great
deal of frustration with the state for
allowing this to happen failing to stop
it particularly for when Mackenzie was
arrested in March this year and then
released the following day prior to that
survivors say he had told his followers
that the world would end in August this
year and that they should starve first
their children and then themselves to
death to be able to go to heaven before
the end of the world after he was
released in March survivors say he then
told his followers that the end of the
world had come closer and it would end
in the middle of April and it's then
according to survivors that hundreds of
people apparently died in the following
weeks before Mackenzie was finally
detained so relatives of some of those
people who died say this could easily
have been prevented if only he'd been
jailed at an earlier stage were told to
starve their children to death survivors
say if they didn't die on time they were
suffocated or hit in the head with blunt
objects and Mackenzie himself said
though just last week when he was
entering the court he denied that he'd
ordered his people to starve themselves
to death
Malcolm Webb reporting from Nairobi
thank you very much